Donald you are gross nobody likes you
but you come back every couple years and
nobody knows why you're like the McRib
when he graduated college he put his
shoulder to the wheel
nose to the grindstone borrowed six
billion dollars from his father and
start a career behind now Donald is very
happy with his lovely wife insert name
here Donald and I have a lot in common
we both live in New York we both play
golf with both fantasize about his
daughter I say stick to your real estate
but all of your buildings are hideous
the Taj Mahal in New Jersey is horrible
there hasn't been a shithole that big on
the shores of New Jersey since the
situation took it to the ass from Pauly
D you know Donald Trump is such a douche
bag that if you look up the word douche
bag in the dictionary there's a picture
expensive Pratt
but if you look close Spencer Pratt is
holding up a picture of Donald Trump